the bomb dome in Hiroshima a lasting
symbol of the consequences of war the
only building here that survived the
atomic bomb
G7 leaders remembering and perhaps
reflecting on what can happen when peace
does not prevail
these Gardens nearby contain a memorial
to the victims of that war as another
rages on in Europe these are Grim times
the UK today announcing farther
sanctions including Banning the import
of Russian diamonds and this a PM
prepared to put on the pressure prime
minister you're announcing the ban on
Russian Diamond Imports and other
sanctions do you expect other G7
countries to follow you this weekend
well I think the most important thing we
can do right now for Global Peace and
Security is to support Ukraine and it's
its struggle against Russia but also to
ensure that Russia pays a price for its
illegal and unprovoked active aggression
that's why we've announced new sanctions
today and I do expect others to follow
my message to Putin is straightforward
and we're not going away
leaders United in their stand to punish
Russia Ukraine's president joining them
this weekend to summon further support
at this Summit but for all the diplomacy
and knock-on for Nations further afield
too net migration in the UK at record
levels Britain welcoming over a hundred
thousand Ukrainian refugees by summer
last year
those are unique circumstances but this
is a long-standing political problem for
the prime minister's party with net
migration soaring and election promises
busted in 2019 you said you would bring
them down below uh 226
000. last year they were 504 000 where
they predicted to go up to 1 million and
you're not acknowledging that at all is
a problem as we've already said is that
the levels of legal migration we want to
bring down I've been very clear about
that I mean I'm absolutely committed to
doing that there's a range of options
that we're looking at let's try and get
a commitment out of you do you commit to
bringing them back down below and 504
000 by the next general election as I
said I'm committed to Bringing Down the
levels of net migration that I've
inherited a new commitment though the PM
Keen to dodge hard numbers but no shine
away from the polls this PM battered at
the local elections not used to he's in
prime minister you're one of life's
success stories you were head boy at
school you had a career in finance that
made you very wealthy now you're prime
minister how do you feel when you lose
sorry how do you feel when you lose how
do you mean that
well you're a winner in life how did you
feel when you don't win well look my my
focus in this job is to deliver for the
country I've set out five very clear
priorities to have inflation grow the
economy reduce debt cut waiting list and
stop the boat
today the opening of this Summit the red
carpet rolled out but these leaders here
for business not pleasure on so many
fronts so many challenges
these leaders have a lot of working out
to do bath Rigby Sky News in Hiroshima